[APPLAUSE]
These are the nominees for
Best Animated Feature Film.
I just had on a loop in my
head, going through that speech
so that I didn't
mess it up because I
felt a real responsibility
in the event that we did win.
Big Hero 6.
I remember the walk down because
as I was walking from the seat
to the stage, in my mind I
could hear all my friends
from around the world cheering.
I kind of blanked out a little
bit and kind of teleported--
Wow.
--to the bottom of the stairs.
And when I came to, I
thought about my mom
because sorry, sorry,
she loves the Oscars.
And I remember watching it
with her when I was young.
And it was special to me
because it was special to her.
Congratulations to all
our fellow nominees.
I remember trying not to focus
because if I ever for a moment
would stop and see
George Clooney,
I would probably mess
up my speech in my head.
So I was just trying to--
Because he's looking
right at you.
Yeah.
At the end, I saw the
mic was available.
And I had to jump
in with my wife.
Love you, Mary.
There's all the parties,
having such a good time.
It's such a good vibe.
You don't want to leave.
And then next thing you
know, it's like hey,
we've got to get to work.
Yeah.
We got to--
--because we've got the
whole crew assembled.
It was a late night.
Early morning.